[Music]
Tristan Thompson breaks his social media
silence after his alleged cheating
scandal on Sunday Khloe Kardashian's
boyfriend and father of her newborn
daughter Tru took to Instagram sharing a
courtside pic of himself at the Quicken
Loans Arena in Cleveland
Tristan wrote in the caption what an
atmosphere in the queue great wig
hashtag on to the next one
while the NBA star may be back in the
game helping his team the Cleveland
Cavaliers beat the Indiana Pacers
Tristan has yet to speak out about the
alleged video of him cozying up to
another woman like I don't even know how
to describe it besides it's just so Kim
Kardashian did not hold back on The
Ellen DeGeneres Show about her sister's
relationship we really were rooting for
Chloe and we still are you know she's so
strong and she's doing the best that she
can it's a really sad situation all over
as for Chloe and Tristan's future
together a source told et they are
making their daughter a priority I'm
gonna figure it all out our source adds
quote Chloe and Tristan continuing as a
couple isn't a sure thing Chloe is
taking time to enjoy being a new mom
before deciding the future of her
relationship there's a million different
emotions that are going on in my brain
you
[Applause]